what do you got for me sweetheart
hey um
the last time i called in um i saw the
comments afterwards and people said that
i was over talking you i do apologize
for that i hope i didn't come across as
rude or anything i'm not worried about
it okay cool
um i was asking and i'm actually wearing
a face mask by the way um i was asking
about kind of the delicate nature of
of men now
um i'm noticing that a lot of the guys
are very
i don't know if it's because there seems
to be a lot of guys who are being raised
by moms or something but i'm noticing
that a lot of guys they're very easy to
emasculate it's one thing if you're kind
of an overbearing like right really
aggressive person
that's what society has manufactured men
into today you know they've they've
basically pussified them
yeah yeah like it's it's really it's
it's really really easy to emasculate
guys now and it's kind of
and it's gotten to the point now where
i'm kind of wondering um
do you find that some of the requests
that not only women are making but some
of the requests that men are making are
a little unreasonable because if you're
if one guy is already kind of super
emasculated he's very effeminate and
he's asking women to
um
yeah submit to him
it kind of requires you to be as a woman
a tinier version of herself correct
deal with him and and that's why i
preface the talk about the green flags
with like you have to be a guy worth
something if you're gonna like vet for
these right like you don't have the
luxury of
saying to a woman make my bed and
continue to do it for me if you're low
value you just don't she's not she's not
even going to do it like the first time
right and it's just a function of
society and societal programming and the
way the state run things and church is a
big beta factory you know today as well
i've had this conversation with rolo
before on his book on religion um
there's a lot of sources out there that
like weaken and soften men and there's a
lot more weak and soft men today than
what there were ever before
which is why it's easier for top shelf
alpha men to stand out from
like
the sea of turkeys there's like a sea of
turkeys and then there's the odd eagle
that's soaring above them all right and
those are the unplugged alphas up there
there's not a lot of them and women have
the expectation for those guys up there
but what they're met with is a bunch of
weak [ __ ] on the ground
mm-hmm um i just wanted to also say um
i had the experience of dealing with a
guy who is
whose former military
and
i'm not sure if you know a lot of people
in the military or people who have like
been successful in the military but his
personality was incredible
um he had the most beautiful home it was
very well manicured even his his dog was
one of the most graceful dogs i've ever
met like there was his life was just so
regime not regimented but it was so full
of discipline and
he just had a way about him that i knew
i just kind of instinctively knew that
if i wanted to be around him i had to be
on my p's and q's
military men are magnificent i have a
lot of friends that are in the military
or have been in the military
special operations guys very like very
interesting people reliable they show up
on time they got your back they know
what brotherhood looks like they're not
pieces of [ __ ] they're not [ __ ]
they're good good people they really are
yeah he uh he was just
i don't know if uh if a lot of the guys
are even interested in kind of being
around military men but there was some
there's just something about him that
he
i i was willing to not compete for him
but i was willing to put
whatever my expectations were i was
willing to kind of
give more ground because i wanted that
guy
right
and and that's what my point is with
this is that women will enter your frame
and complement your life if you're a guy
worthy of that which is why you yielded
to gi joe but the regular you know
pussified guys you wouldn't do that
right yeah no they demanded of you they
demand you that you submit yourself to
them and they and they act absolutely
yeah they ask that you make yourself
smaller so like even you were talking
earlier about um like your own business
and things like that i think i think
it's
from what i've seen most women are
desperate to have men who pride
themselves on leadership so we want to
be a part of making you a king yeah and
it's not that it's not that
men like that want you smaller
they just don't want you getting in the
way and complicating their lives right
they want you to compliment it
yeah so it's so it's not about being
smaller like it's not like you know he's
got to be bigger so you can be smaller i
mean he's obviously i mean generally
speaking going to be physically more
imposing because he's a male men are
generally bigger than women
and stronger too so
it's not about bigger smaller it's about
you know complementing you know like
bringing the feminine skills to the
table so that the masculine and the
feminine can work together better
together like you know
men would like i'm not about dividing
men and women like i like people get
this wrong all the time oh rich why are
you misogynist whitey hate women blah
blah blah i don't know where they get
that idea from because all i'm telling
guys is to take ownership from a lot you
know for their lives man up and become
something and i'm telling women to
preserve themselves and not be hosed
basically
it it's actually pretty interesting that
um
even when i'm talking to men and i'm
trying to figure out you know what
exactly is going on beneath the surface
the amount of men who just kind of
there's a wit
i think a lot of men have just given up
i think oh yeah a lot of them have
absolutely they just
they just throw up their hands jenna and
they go it's not worth it the juice is
not worth the squeeze women what do
women bring to the table
i'll tell you what women bring to the
table they can do my laundry they can
cook for me they can
form a connection with my kid
right they can take care of me when i'm
sick it's not just sex right
a lot of guys are just like well you
know beyond sex what are women good for
a good woman that sees you as a high
value guy will want to compliment your
life will want to do those things for
you
yeah and that's so true and i shouldn't
be a struggle yeah it's true and i've
also seen it in my own life men who have
i've heard men actually ask the question
what did what do women bring to the
table and my first the first sign that
in my head that i'm not dealing with a
successful man is him asking that
question well
you know i'll be honest with you jenna a
lot of these guys spend way too much
time consuming content on the internet
and youtube with dudes trying to hold
women accountable but there's these like
low value ratchet clanky like women that
you just wouldn't have anything to do
with but they you know you throw that up
on on screen and she's like i want a guy
that makes six figures and then
and and then they just like well you
know that you're like a single mom with
three kids in tow from three different
fathers and you have a hundred grand of
student debt right i don't care i wanna
and it just becomes good entertainment
value yeah that's where they come up
with these notions that women have
nothing to offer
yeah like even um like even in our last
sorry i know i'm rambling here but even
in our last conversation when we were
talking about yellowstone um yeah like
john dutton's wife even though she
wasn't really in it
you that short period of time that you
got to see her you got to see the kind
of value that she brought to his life
strong men have strong women behind them
so if you want like i've i've never
i've experienced men who are really
really strong and they wanted me to be
on my p's and q's which made me better
and then i've also experienced men who
basically were looking for mommies and a
lot of guys are looking for mommies
which if you look for mom like i've
experienced men who are looking for one
to mother them and when you become a
mother to a dude
what does that look like generally
speaking when you got to mother them you
said nagging them so so yeah so
basically like the guys that do things
like um you know
he he say for example he doesn't like
his job
and he'll come home and he'll complain
about his job but when you say well are
you looking for a new one oh i don't
want to work for anybody nobody should
be telling me what to do okay so are you
planning on going and becoming an
entrepreneur like looking into nfts
looking into crypto what are you doing
nothing but he still wants you to sit
there and listen to him yeah and yeah
and then he still and and the basic
things that he needs to do as a man to
kind of keep his life moving so for
example going to the gym
um going to the doctors
making sure that he takes care of his
responsibilities making sure that you
know if he says he's going to sign up
for this course and take it he does it
when he says he's going to do it he
doesn't do it so you end up nagging him
and then he complains that you're like
his mom yeah so these are these are what
i call low value guys that haven't done
the work on themselves and they have the
wrong expectations right um
and a lot of it is is you know nature
nurture sort of thing but there's a
point where
you become an adult
i don't care what that is 16 19 20.
whatever that looks like but there's a
point where you become an adult and you
can't cry like a little [ __ ] about what
you're all about in your life you have
to look around and i mean like quite
quite simply guys because jenna's
brought it up a couple times now if you
don't know what a masculine virtuous
competent
strong guy looks like watch yellowstone
john dutton
rip look at guys like that because women
right now and i'll tell you this because
i was watching these interviews with
these um actors the other day women
right now are falling head over heels
for men like this on a tv show yeah
right the character they love that [ __ ]
yeah and and then this whole thing of
like women won't date me because i don't
have money
um
uh what's it called that is not true
we we
we just want to know that you can handle
things
you be surprised there's well there's
different phases of life like how old
are you jenna
oh i'm 28.
so a 20-something guy that's a chad
looking guy that has a plan will still
be attractive to you but if the guy's
let's say 42 and he's got nothing to
show for himself but he still has some
ambition doesn't matter how good-looking
he is the 20-year-old guy looks more
attractive 100 of the time yeah that's
true that's true right so it really all
depends on how old the guy and where
that's at and i've talked about that
part before too
yeah like that's that's very true um
i just i was just curious because i was
talking to some of my girlfriends and
we're all having the same problem
everyone all of us want to be in happy
healthy stable relationships we want the
you know we want our own john dutton's
we want our own rips and we're even
willing to make some concessions with
the fact that he may not be the highest
earning but it is he good with his hands
if something breaks in the house can he
fix it can if he can't make money can he
save us some
and and
the guys are just
they're they're basically you know women
with
penises like they're kind of they're
useless like pretty much yeah
oh well well thank you
jenna next time camera on you know
everybody's asking to see your face
right we got sperling here when are you
going to show your face come on well
here well here's what i'll do um if you
have an email address i can email you a
picture of me and i can explain to you
why i prefer to be off camera it's on
the about page of the youtube channel
the email is right there you can shoot
me an email that way okay groovy i'll do
it groovy
all right thanks
you